derniers jours ici à maurice on est sur
le départ on part d'ici quelques heures
et justement aujourd'hui avant de partir
je voulais profiter d'un cadre
exceptionnel continue à rester dans un
cadre exceptionnel à un peu l'humour
ivoirien site pour vous parler justement
d'un smartphone clochette depuis
quelques jours j'ai avec moi que j'ai
emmené en vacances mais je connais mais
a pu me dire que c'était ça la
surveiller mes devoirs de vacances c'est
celui-là c'est le chiot miss et le mit à
3 l'heure l'année dernière vous avez
emmené avec moi à madrid pour aller
découvrir le mia 2002 light cette année
on a mis à trois îles et la justesse
depuis quelques jours il a des poils
sont vraiment très très positif
si les trucs un petit peu en dessous ce
que je propose d'aller faire un petit
tour
on allait se balader sur la plage un
tranquillement on va se détend se mettre
à la cale et pour aller voir un petit
peu se mit à troyes il a regardé la sas
et la petite fiole de vacances qu'on
avait on n'est quand même pas mal avec
le lit des lionnes juste là et là
derrière jeu montrant que la résidence
est ce que on est pas mal
il ya pire allez je vous emmène avec moi
comme ça vous allez me dire ce que vous
en pensez après en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
bon je vous emmène en bord de plage là
on est pas mal derniers jours vacances
départ demain grand vol un fait
on parque de l'île maurice jusqu'à dubaï
est une halte de quelques heures ensuite
dubai/paris ce très long mais c'est pas
grave c'est très sympa d'ailleurs si un
jour vous en avez l'occasion de les voir
ici c'est très très bien l'île maurice
est vraiment très très bel endroit les
gens sont adorables à cuisiner et épicé
est très bonne pour moi c'est plutôt
cool donc aujourd'hui nous parle de ce
smartphone là c'est le mit à 3-2 chez
aubry qui était présenté il ya quelques
jours smartphones qui est intéressant
sur certains points un peu plus le fait
qu'un autre point notre côté on est sur
un smartphone qui coûte un peu moins de
250 euros
249 90 c gepa des tisons qu'il peut pas
tout avoir alors déjà ne serait ce qu'en
termes de design de prise en main le
produit est vachement bien finir il ya
une vraie maîtrise de la partie schumi
ça c'est pas nouveau on est sur un
smartphone qui hume le 2019 a plané avec
7 en cause goutte d'eau avec des bords
noirs un peu sur le côté de l'écran mais
dans l'absolu c'est pas très très grave
c'est quand tout cas ça qui va me poser
problème au niveau de ce smartphone les
finitions sont belles vous avez du verre
à l'avant à la vente plutôt là à
l'arrière aussi cdu corning gorilla
glass 1go résistants de bonne qualité
protéger le camp même je vous invite
vraiment à me remettre une coque de
protection là dessus parce que sinon
vous risquez quand même d'avoir des
déconvenues assez rapide
par contre un smartphone que ce combat
c'est léger fait 173 g la prise en main
est bonne vous pouvez l'utiliser à une
main quasiment voir admirer importe à
gratter sur le haut de l'écran laisse
non absolue ça marche bien vous avez un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé sous l'écran que je trouve assez
réactif donc ça c'est plutôt bien sur un
smartphone de cette qualité se rappelle
de ce positionnement tarifaire
on va reconnaître le général on attend
un petit peu là ça va il réagit plutôt
bien un petit design avec un dos 3d
courbet à l'arrêt fabrice tout cas il ya
de belles finitions le produit est bien
fait logoté shiomi android one c'est un
produit de bonne qualité de bonne
facture donc ça d'emprunt d'autres
captures non design plan esthétique la
copie est maîtrisé et de ce point de vue
elle vous sera absolument pas déçu par
contre je trouve que là où le bât blesse
un peu c'est au niveau de l'écran vous
avez un écran de 6 pouces et un écran à
moi donc ça c'est vachement bien que si
on me fait le choix de nous mettre dans
cette gamme de produits un écran amoled
plus tôt du lcd
à côté de ça la dalle est pas génial
l'écran n'est pas super lumineux l'aï si
vous avez quand même de la lumière on
voit pas grand chose en plein jour ça
c'est vraiment le point de regret alors
je peux pas dire qu'on voit rien c'est
pas vrai on voit mais voilà ils
demanderaient quand même avoir un peu
plus de luminosité donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose que que je vais
venir regretter et je regrette aussi la
résolution
1560 par 720 pixels on n'est même pas
sur du full hd on est sur du hdz bail
je fais un peu un peu importe mais tu es
là dessus alors à côté ça c'est deux
points un peu négatifs apporte de
l'autonomie comme il va pas être très
lumineux il va pas venir trop consommer
mais en terme d'usagé en termes de
confort de visionnage pour causé un
petit peu moyen à côté de cela le
rassure et bien vous avez un écran 19
points 5/9 c'est ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui ça marche bien dans plus qu
il est strictement impossible en
attendant les paramètres de venir
modifier la calibration de l'écran il
est comme il est il est tel qu'il est il
bougera pas que ça vous plaise ou non au
niveau du côté multimédia avec de
l'audio gars vous avez un haut parleur
mono sur le bas donc on va pas
s'attendre à voir un truc incroyable il
marchera correctement si vous écoutez de
la vidéo comme ça avec votre haut
parleurs uniquement dans des lieux non
bruyant bien évidemment par contre vous
avez une prise jack qui est là qui
marche plutôt bien ça c'est le point
c'est positif c'est pas mal mais là où
ça devient vraiment intéressant c'est le
côté performances autonomie il est
équipé du stade ragone 665 côté
graphique adreno 610 ça marche
merveilleusement bien alors attention on
n'est pas faire tourner des jeux avec de
la 3d
un truc de ouf mais pour faire tourner
un peuple j pour faire tourner beaucoup
de jeu en tout cas du duplex tort ça
marche pas parfaitement mais surtout pas
que c'est très très positif c'est
l'autonomie vous avez une énorme
batterie de 4030 milliampères heures de
recharge d'iwate qui inclut faut un peu
plus de deux heures à peu près deux
heures en tout cas pour le recharger
mais cette batterie elle est vraiment
hyper optimiser le fait d'avoir android
one d'avoir cette dalle oled même si
l'état très lumineuse mais ça me donne
une grosse autonomie vous le tenez plus
de deux jours peut être un peu plus
entre deux haies les deux jours et demi
ça dépend plus des usages alors il pas
vous dire je vais l'acheter par une
course qui obligerait tout le temps tu
sais pas vrai ça dépend vraiment de vos
usages vous allez perdre d'un côté en
qualité au niveau de l'écran ça va être
un peu moyen mais par contre si vous
avez besoin d'une grosse autonomie si
vous voulez un smartphone que pouvait
emmener partout c'est pas de l'outdoor
mais je dirais partout sur un usage
ville et vous voyez une grosse autonomie
là dessus vous êtes tranquilles en plus
il est compatible avec la recharge
rapide 18 watts qui n'est pas fournie à
kiev alward est recherché en plus vous
avoir rechargé plus rapidement dont ça
c'est gérer le gros point le gros gros
gros point positif de ce produit
autre point qui est sympa c'est l'ouest
vous tournez sur un android once et de
l'android purent alors y'a juste d'une
petite option qui était rajouter notre
xiaomi mais sinon c'est vraiment de
l'android pur et c'est vraiment ce que
j'apprécie
on a l'habitude d'avoir mis ouailles on
on n'aime pas on furent couche pour ça
c'est une question goût mais là le fait
d'avoir cet androïde pur moi je trouve
ça vraiment génial et en tout cas si
comme moi vous aimez beaucoup
des smartphones type cloud mpixels 3
pour notamment ce que tu es en gros hits
pure android il ya là dessus en tout cas
vous allez retrouver vous serez
absolument pas déçu maintenant dernier
point d dernier point et non des
moindres c'est la partie photo comme
vous l'avez vu là vous avez un triple
capteur photo alors le premier appareil
c'est un 48 mégapixels un petit moment
maintenant que je suis au menu propose
depuis début de l'année d'ailleurs des
48 mégapixels c'est la sonic 582 qui
marchent merveilleusement bien 40e il ya
toutes celles qui ouvre à f 1.79 d'armes
est d'avoir la technologie 4 pixels en
or en gros vous allez prendre quatre
gros pixels vous les mettez ensemble ça
vous faire un gros pixels os 4 qui
captera plus de lumière et puis surtout
ça me sortirait une photo de 12
mégapixels qui sensiblement tout cas
sera de meilleure qualité capture à plus
de détails et plus de lumière c'est un
peu ça l'idée du truc il n'y a pas de
tels objectifs à tout ce dont vous aurez
un zoom x 2 c'est un zoom absolument
numérique et vous avez une caméra grand
angle de 118,2 grèce une caméra 8
mégapixels couvrat f 2.2 qui est pas mal
alors elle va avoir un poids un peu
négatif elle va un petit peu déformé
mais c'est pas hyper hyper hyper grave
et la troisième caméra c'est une caméra
de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui
est là pour le mode portrait pour les
fai de bloquer et à l'avant vous avez
une caméra du 30 2 mégapixels couvrat f
2.0 qui bénéficie également la
technologie de 4 pixels en est il
sortira en gros une photo en 8
mégapixels capture a plus de lumière bon
voilà pourquoi pas ça c'est intéressant
alors que dire ces photos moi je trouve
que déjà lorsque vous avez des
connaissances de bonne luminosité
là par exemple issement l'extérieur pour
la beauté des paysages la caméra de 48
milliards que celle marche
merveilleusement bien pour sectionner
personne qui peut venir saturé pour des
images qui sont un petit peu au dessus
de ce qu'il est en réalité on a aussi sa
malle de lissage là je trouve que c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal
un peu saturé mais ça fonctionne donc du
point de vue retrait de la caméra
principale la caméra 40e il ya celle dés
lors que vous avez de la lumière là
dessus vous est absolument essentielle
vous n'aurez aucun problème et ça pour
moi c'est vachement cool maintenant dès
que vous arrivez sur des photos il ya un
peu moins lumière par l'obscurité des
photos nuit là il fait - le job on va
récupérer beaucoup plus de bruit c'est
plus imprécis et les tentatives de
lissage assure que d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est pas terrible
c'est pas notre côté un smartphone
premium on est bien sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme il faut en avoir
conscience produire 250 euros donc on
n'a pas trop trop lui en demander mais
par contre le boulot qui fait au niveau
de cette caméra de 48 mégapixels en
plein jour c'est parfait cherchez pas à
les faire des photos nymex à ça marchera
pas le grand angle et bien il est moins
bien en qualité
clairement ce serait très clair
là-dessus mais par contre pour avoir
capté des monuments vous pourriez pas
capté autrement et bien ça fait toujours
son petit effet c'est pas mal tandis qu
effectivement la caméra 2 mégapixels
pour mode portrait marche pas mal
ni détours correctement une fois de plus
on n'a pas non plus lui demander la lune
on n'est pas sur le le processeur n'est
pas sur le socle le plus performant mais
il fait quand même le taf essaie toutes
celles filles aussi sont assez correcte
assez honnête il y en à dire de tout
cela vous moi je trouve que c'est un
appareil qui est vraiment bien pour
faire des photos lorsque vous avez
beaucoup de lumière à l'avant comme à
l'arrière le grand temps que je vous lis
bien mais c'est pas la revoir le
meilleur rendu mais si par contre vous
voulez faire des photos nuit oublier ce
smartphone il sera pas fait pour vous à
côté de sa banque est intéressant si
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir soit
une double carte sim soit une carte sim
plus une carte microsd pour venir monter
votre stockage 4 250 gigas non ça c'est
plutôt cool vous avez de l'infrarouge
donc si vous l'utilisez comme une petite
télécommande vous pouvez le faire vous
n'avez pas de nfc donc ici pas de
paiement dématérialisé et google paye
puisque vous voulez ça c'est strictement
impossible avec votre pass navigo ou les
transports en commun ça ne marchera pas
par contre vous avez du bluetooth 15.0
et il n'a pas de certification ip67 pas
ip68 donc en tout cas sur le papier
donné comme n'étant pas étanche alors
rassurez vous si un petit peu d'eau qui
vient est déçu mais ça devrait quand
même plutôt pas mal se passer
éviter de jeter dans la piscine un
aquarium lorsque vous voulez c'est ça ou
vous resterez dans des problèmes mais
normalement ça on ne le fait pas et
c'est un smartphone vous pouvez trouver
en eux config dans tous les cas 4 gigas
de ram manqué du gua drame 64 giga de
stockage à 249,90 un peu moins de 250
tours bien tout petit peu moins et 4
gigas de ram 128 cas de stockage à 281
et si c'est un produit qui vous
intéresse et bien vous a mis un lien en
bas dans la description pour faire 1 1
point de vue un peu global à qui
s'adresse ce smartphone nokia qui
s'adresse à des personnes qui veulent
pas consommer du multimédia qui veulent
pas de qualité qui veut pas la qualité
de l'écran la qualitéde à la qualité des
haut parleurs
on cherche pas ça là on cherche un
smartphone en dur encore pouvoir emmener
partout avec soi qui va tenir plus d'une
journée on veut pas se poser la question
de la batterie on va faire des photos de
trois photos souvenirs en plein jour en
ça marchera bien mais ce qu'on cherche
vraiment là dessus sur tout
c'est l'endurance c'est la polyvalence
et le fait de ne pas s'embêter d'avoir
un truc est quand même assez rapide
amateurs de multimédia vous passez votre
tour même si l'écran est quand même
relativement correcte des qui est un peu
le devenir c'est moi ça fasse vrai luxe
c'est à vous de meilleur temps ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous le trouvez se mit à trois
choses
comment vous trouvez par rapport
intéressant aurait mis notre set est ce
que vous pensez qu'il peut lui faire de
l'ombre
oui non quoi comment marquer moi tout
seul au bar aux commentaires
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait
d'avoir un écran amoled là dessus avec
une petite résolution parce que vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne idée une
fausse bonne idée
voilà moi je suis un peu dubitatif
c'est bien qu'il ya un écran amoled dans
cette gamme de prix se trouve face à des
smartphones quand même qu'ils sont d'une
grosse compétition dans cette gamme là
mais je me serais attendent au minimum
avoir du full hd là-dessus alesi a pas
de souci je me serais attendu au minimum
là-dessus avoir du full hd voilà ça
c'est un peu le le truc qui gâche un peu
à peu la fête dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas voilà quant à moi il est
l'heure de repartir prendre l'avion les
vacances sont terminées et là je vais
rester dans un mode je pense un petit
peu plus light
jusqu'à fin août ils sortent bien
préparer la rentrée
j'ai vachement de projets on en reparle
d'ici quelques jours mais rassurez vous
continuerez à bord du contenu voilà sur
ce je fais des vomissements
et puis à très bientôt